On June 3rd, 1098, 927 years ago today,
a dramatic Christian victory over
Islamic oppression took place. The
liberation of the ancient Christian city
of Antioch, where the very word
Christian was first coined. See the book
of Acts
11:26. Background. Following the battle
of Manzikert in 1071, also known in the
Chronicles as that dreadful day, Turkish
invaders began to overrun Asia Minor,
formerly a bastion of Christianity.
Today,
Turkey, some
quotes. Far and wide they, the Muslim
Turks, ravaged cities and castles
together with their settlements, wrote a
Frankish eyewitness. Churches were
raised to the ground of the clergymen
and monks whom they captured. Some were
slaughtered, while others were with
unspeakable wickedness given up, priests
and all, to their dire dominion, and
nuns, alas, for the sorrow of it, were
subjected to their lusts.
Because the atrocities were so many and
widespread, we actually have a
remarkably large number of contemporary
writings documenting
them. For example, an anonymous Georgian
chronicler wrote that quote, "Holy
churches served as stables for their
horses. The priests were immolated, that
is burned alive during the holy
communion itself. The virgins were
defiled, the youth circumcised, and the
infants taken away." Ana Kamenna, the
princess at Constantinople, wrote that,
quote, "The cities were obliterated,
lands were plundered, and the whole of
Anatolia was stained with Christian
blood." Outraged to hear what was
happening in the east, Christians from
all over Europe, led by the Franks and
Normans, set out on what would become
the first crusade, roughly between 1096
and 1099.
After entering and winning several
battles in Turkont controlled Asia
Minor, by October 1097, the Europeans
were at and besieging the walls of
Antioch. For long, Antioch had resisted
Islam. Quote, "Even when all the east
was shaken, and the successors of
Muhammad, meaning the four righteous
Khalifs, were subjugating by force
entire provinces to their impious
superstition and perverse dogma, that is
Islam." Chronicler William of Tier
continues to write, "Antioch had quote,
as long as possible, refused to bear the
domination of an infidel nation. That is
until the Turks captured it in 1084. Now
more than a decade later, its indigenous
Christians were being much abused and
oppressed by their Turkish master Yahi
Seyan, a notorious persecutor of
Christians, who, to further mock them,
had also converted Antioch's ancient
cathedral into a horse stable." Quote,
"Alas, how many Christians, Greeks,
Syrians, and Armenians who lived in the
city of Antioch were killed by the mad
Turks," lamented one crusader
eyewitness. "With the Franks looking
on," he continues, "they threw outside
the walls the heads of those Christians
killed with their catapults and slings.
This especially grieved our people." But
because the warrior aristocracy of
Europe had no qualms about engaging in a
bit of tit fortat, the Norman leader
Bound quote brought those Muslims he had
captured back to the gate of the city
where to terrify the Muslim citizens of
Antioch who were watching he ordered
that they all be decapitated and their
severed heads catapulted over the city
walls. The aforementioned Byzantine
princess Anna Kamenna, who had earlier
met and described the Bohund as a
towering marvel for the eyes to behold.
He was apparently a giant, added that,
quote, "A certain charm hung about this
man, but was partly marred by a general
heir of the horrible. He was clearly not
one to be cowed by Islamic terror
tactics." Another crusade leader, Duke
Godfrey of Buon, also quote performed
there a famous deed worthy of
remembrance forever in front of the
walls of Antioch, wrote Robert the monk,
a contemporary, a feat which rendered
him illustrious in the eyes of the
entire army. During a particularly
brutal battle before the walls of
Antioch, a Turkish chieftain, bolder
than the rest, larger and more heavily
built, saw the Duke savaging his men
mercilessly, writes Robert. He
continues, quote, "So the Muslim chief
urged his horse towards him towards
Godfrey with bloodstained spurs, and
lifting his sword high, he sliced
through the whole shield of the Duke,
which he held above his head. If the
Duke had not parried the blow with the
boss of the shield, and twisted over to
the other side, he would have paid the
debt of death." The Duke, now ablaze
with furious anger, prepared to return
the blow, and thus aimed for his neck.
He raised his sword and plunged it into
the left side of his shoulder blades
with such force that it split the chest
down the middle, slashed through the
spine and vital organs, and slippery
with blood and gore came out unbroken
above the right leg. As a result, the
whole of the head and the right side
slipped down into the water, while the
part remaining on the horse was carried
back into the city. All those inside
rushed together to see this horrible
sight and were struck with amazement,
panic, and fear, overcome with terror.
Here there were screams like those of a
woman in labor, their voices raised in
misery because he had been one of their
great amirs. The terrified Muslims
retreated back into Antioch during this
battle and unleashed a hailtorm of
missiles and arrows directly onto
Godfrey, but he successfully withdrew.
It was a great victory and allowed the
Christians to tighten the noose around
the city. Still, nearly 8 months had
passed since the Europeans first laid
siege to Antioch and still it would not
be breached. Many crusaders died of
starvation, thirst, and pestilence.
Desperate crusaders were reduced to
eating dogs, rats, and thistles.
Eventually, a Muslim tower captain, an
Armenian Christian who had been
converted to Islam during Yahi's
persecutions, made a deal with Bohund.
As a result, on today's date, June the
3rd, 1098, under the cover of night, the
emaciated crusaders, having
clandestinely climbed over the walls
into the city, were seen running wildly
a muk, slaughtering anyone in sight. As
a result, quote, those who were
Christians began to chant Kirleson, the
Christian mantra, which means Lord have
mercy in Greek, to make it clear to our
men that they were not Turks, but
Christians, continues Robert the monk.
Once their startle was over, these same
Christians, Robert continues, quote,
Syrians, Armenians, and the true
believers of other nations rejoiced
exceedingly over what had happened,
meaning over the crusader takeover of
Antioch. He continues, "They at once
took arms and joined forces with the
army."
This is a rather telling quote. As you
might recall, I made a video some weeks
back, link in the description, showing
how academics such as Oxford published
John Espazito insist that the Christians
of the Near East were just loving Muslim
rule in the years before the First
Crusade and had no reason whatsoever to
want European Christians come to their
aid. Here is yet another example that
flatly contradicts this lie. At any
rate, the Christians, both Western and
Eastern, overcame their enemies and
retook Antioch on that day. Today,
although Yahi can managed to escape the
carnage, local Christians tracked,
killed, beheaded, and hurled their
former tormentor's head into the view of
all the Christian princes, wrote the
chronicler. And he continues, the head
was of enormous size. The ears were very
wide and hairy. His hair was white, and
he had a beard which flowed. The
Europeans remained and recuperated in
the ancient Christian city for the rest
of the year. Bound was crowned prince of
Antioch. The crusaders sent a letter to
the pope in Rome chronicling their
triumphs and tragedies and urging him to
come in person to Antioch reminding him
that it was quote here that the name
Christian was born. Although the
crusaders had won the battle, the war
was just beginning and a massive Muslim
army was on its way to annihilate these
insulent upstarts. But that is a story
for another time. Bye.
Heat. Heat.